finally we have chuck todd chuck todd is
a journalist over at cb
nbc news uh and as you can see even he's
getting very concerned about how bad
it's looking for the democrats let's
look at presidential job approval rating
all right when when uh bill clinton and
george w bush had midterms that went
their way their job approval rating was
was right around 50 or north of it all
right when you start dipping below 45
you've got a problem and you're going to
have midterms that are in the bad to
shellacking ratio president biden's at
40. george w bush was at 39 in 2006
we know how that turned out so you see
that's also in shellacking territory
then let's look at the generic ballot
what you're going to see here is a
narrow leave for the republicans 42 to
44 and you're going to say oh that's
competitive
no no no no in in national polling it's
extremely rare because the way
gerrymandering has worked uh the way
democrats are packed into districts you
know they have more 85 districts and the
republicans do the bottom line is
generic ballot if the democrats are
losing it means they're going to get
walloped last time in 2010 republicans
had a two point advantage that
translated to 63 seats so
in summary right now you've got three
essentially three numbers here that all
point into dangerous territory for the
democrats in the incumbent party
presidential job rating at 40 percent
wrong track over 70 percent and the
republicans leading in the generic
ballot
not a good time
the last line that's the giveaway that's
the tell
right if you were playing cards with
this guy not a good time what do you
mean i thought you were an impartial
journalist oh but your guys are losing
so not a good time that's how you end
the segment you give all the numbers
let's just go on the assumption that
those numbers are roughly right or trust
trustworthy etc etc he obviously feels
those are not a good time this is a lot
of trouble because it's his guys it's
his administration it's his machine
so they they're telling you what they
are do you think if it had been reversed
and it looked like democrats were gonna
sweep and crush and all of the stuff was
gonna happen and blue wave and
everything else do you think he would
end it by like oh [ __ ] man we're screwed
not a good time
pretty sure he wouldn't
in case he didn't see what i was doing